aujourd'hui pour notre calendrier de
l'avent 100 % hivinois je vous propose
d'aller du côté du parc zoologique de
Toir ouvert depuis 1968 dans les
[Musique]
iblines pour Noël pourquoi ne pas offrir
un passe annuel pour revenir plusieurs
fois sur ce site qui fait plus de 350
hactares les visiteurs peuvent y croiser
plus de 750 animaux et 110 espèces le
passe annuel est à 62 € pour les adultes
et à 45 € pour les enfants de 3 à 11 ans
si vous voulez prolonger l'aventure vous
pouvez également dormir au plus près des
animaux vous pouvez dormir au côté des
loups ou des ours dans des tanières
situées en pleine nature ou si vous êtes
plutôt éléphant vous pouvez dormir dans
des lODES pour dormir au plus près de
ces apachidermes dans les deux cas des
animations sont proposées avec des
soigneurs ou des Rangers pour être au
plus près à des animaux de quoi passer
d'excellents moments en famille ou entre
amis